i have to remind myself all the time if
i send out a particularly
not even edgy i don't really tweet edgy
things i don't think but if i tweet
something that gets a lot of engagement
from people on the opposite side of the
political spectrum i'm so guilty of
seeing some account say something like
really stupid and i'm like i have to
quote tweet them and dunk on them and
it's literally someone with an egg as
their profile picture
and it's and that's why like the
addiction aspect of it is so
crazy to me because
it really does fire off like those
receptors in your brain that make you
want to engage constantly and scroll
constantly and even someone who is aware
of it has that impulse and imagine how
bad that is for people who don't really
understand what's happening so elon musk
buys this big stake in twitter but i'm
not entirely convinced that it matters
because it's it's the cultural issues on
uh our in our society outside of twitter
matter more so in in your instance amber
you got fired because you tweeted a joke
about kamala harris
that was
you made fun of the way she dressed
that's right they called you racist on
twitter yeah so uh basically what
happened was a month ago was the state
of the union and kamala was wearing this
horrific brown
suit which like everybody agreed that it
was ugly
right i don't think i'm the only one
that thought it was bad uh i saturday
night live made fun of it and there were
people like photoshopping her to look
like a ups employee
and so i decided to throw out this tweet
saying kamala looks like a ups employee
what can brown do for you nothing good
apparently because obviously she's
ineffective at public policy and bad at
her job
well a few days later how this all
actually shook out was
i don't know if you guys remember this
there were a bunch of protests at the
university of north texas
because the young conservatives club on
campus had decided to invite this guy
named jeff younger and jeff younger is a
dad whose son was taken away from him
because
the mom was convinced that the son was
actually a daughter and wanted to
transition him medically and the dad was
not about it so young conservatives for
texas had this guy come to campus and of
course the
sjws on campus freaked out had these
crazy protests and i
got involved in this debate on twitter
again never a good idea but here we are
um in the
replies to matt walsh actually
and there's this freelance reporter for
the daily beast yahoo news uh rolling
stone i think named steven monicelli and
i point to him as like the root cause of
all of this
he
took a screenshot of the kamala tweet
because he was mad at me for saying you
can't chemically castrate kids
and
sent it to all of his followers and his
followers decided that they were going
to start emailing my employers to say
that i was a racist and needed to be
fired and what where where were you
working so i was with the spectator
wmal which was a radio station based in
dc it's like the conservative talk radio
station in dc and then i have a
fellowship with the steamboat institute
the spectator wmal wmal and it's a part
of cumulus media that's like the
corporation that owns a bunch of radio
stations so they're trash they're trash
they're operated by a bunch of liberals
who don't care about anything outside
it's called conservative radio they make
all their money from conservative radio
but they don't actually believe in
anything that their hosts are saying on
air is this long and short of it the
spectator literally laughed at these
emails they were getting because they
thought they were so ridiculous
wmal a week later calls me after i host
the show on a wednesday morning
and tells me that my tweet was racist
that it violated their social media
policy and that they were terminating me
effective immediately no severance
nothing i was done i wasn't going back
on the show the next day
they didn't inform anybody else on the
show that i was hosting so they were
like sol they didn't even have a host
for the next morning they had to have
somebody else fill in
they didn't tell the wmal program
director
it was a vice president and the vp of hr
i have the termination letter and
everything that confirms everything that
i'm telling you guys people you worked
with didn't stand up for you and be like
i'm not going to do it
they tried i will say that there was a
lot of internal maneuvering over the
past month which is why i've waited so
long to go public with the story because
i wanted to see if cumulus and wmail
would do the right thing a lot of the
hosts are on contract so they can't
really just walk out uh without facing
pretty heavy financial
uh consequences
i don't want to throw them under the bus
because they have been speaking out on
my behalf publicly since i've talked
about this this morning
but i understand your perspective
yeah i wish people were more willing to
uh
just
stand up
consequences be damned there are so many
people on the left there that are
are willing to risk prison time
burning down police stations and doing
the most insane things and conservatives
won't even risk a contract violation
it's like oh no a contract violation
you're gonna have to go into arbitration
those companies don't want to spend
money on lawyers yeah that you know so
if you were like i'm not going to do the
show they'll be like well you're in
breach of you'll be in breach of
contract and it's like okay spend five
dollars retaining your lawyer because i
i refuse to do a show one day and let's
see how much money you got to waste
before you get me to agree a monthly
i'll tell you this i just it just pisses
me off they'd come to me and they'd say
you're in breach of contract we're gonna
sue you i say okay i'm gonna wait you
out however long it takes you to put
your lawyers on retainer to foul and
then what i'm gonna do i'm gonna let you
win then i'm gonna make you sync 20
grand into legal fees then i'll come
back how does that sound or you can just
say we're not going to fire someone over
a tweet people just aren't willing to
even put a little bit of pressure on
their companies yeah and i will say
i was allowed to go on dan bongino's
show today and dan bongino's show is
nationally syndicated one of the radio
stations that hosts his program from 12
to 3 p.m every day wmal
so i got to go on the radio station that
fired me and tell all of their listeners
exactly what the company did to me and
dan bongino was actually kind enough to
offer me a bi-weekly segment on the show
as well so he's putting his money where
his mouth is i mean he also
and he's gotten into it with cumulus
before over their vaccine mandate so
this isn't the first time like he he
hates them rightfully totally
understandable if you've seen their like
internal and i can't go into too much
because of the confidentiality agreement
i don't think they'll sue me but i
would rather not risk it they have a lot
of stuff on their internal company
forums that is just horrendous i mean if
the listeners knew the things that they
were promoting internally whether it's
some of the trainings that they do or
some of the financial bonuses they offer
people for doing certain things they
would be absolutely horrified that they
are giving their listenership to this
company sounds like project veritas
might be picking something up from there
yeah i would love to see james o'keefe
do a little digging on that
i'm not surprised that these
corporations don't care about anything
yeah i'm also not surprised there are a
lot of people who are like well there's
nothing i can do about it because you
know i'm under contract and i'm also not
surprised that dan bongino was like i
don't care let's do it because dan is
doing a lot to push back you know he's
invested in rumble they've got something
called parallel economy do you guys know
about this uh only by name alternative
uh a financial transaction service so
cool you're you're they're building you
know i'm a big proponent of supporter of
and working towards parallel systems
right for a while i just talked about
how it was it was dangerous and this was
this was years ago i was like if they
keep banning people this way if
financial institutions keep doing this
you're going to make a parallel economy
you do not want that now we're here and
it's like okay if that's what they
wanted it's it's it will pass it you've
got to do it so parallel economy if you
you could do a subscription service and
not have to worry about being banned by
someone tweet you know tweeting oh but
they're racist or whatever this
company's gonna be like yeah we don't
care and dan mangino i believe he's an
investor i'm not entirely sure i know
he's involved so man at least we have
people like him doing stuff that's
that's something yeah i mean if i were a
host on that station still i would be
terrified about what could happen to me
because you can't do political
commentary if you can't make fun of a
politician's outfit like that is the
most basic of things that you should be
allowed to do how are you supposed to go
on the air and tell the listeners that
you're committed to truth if you work
for a company that censors you if you
get anywhere close to the edge which i
don't even think this was i to me this
is like one of the most clear-cut cases
of just dishonest bad faith cancel
culture [ __ ]
but
that's that's how it is nowadays like
you can't say anything um and you have
to be so anodyne and boring
that it is literally destroying
political commentary i think people have
been too
uh too pla complacent with uh corporate
corporations they've gone too far
they're not people
yeah they need to be that whole system
needs to be shattered and it's great
it's it's it's beyond it's an aberration
now it needs to be changed how many uh
ballpark how many people you know worked
directly or indirectly with you
with me on the show
uh
maybe five
if those five people were like we're all
sick today
they'd be like higher amber back
apologize to her
yeah instead they're just like well i'm
not gonna do anything
you know that's the thing that people
understand it's not even about
you know stepping on the toes and trying
to you know cause some pain to the
company who's playing bs it's just
literally being like oh we must have all
got sick at the same time i mean we all
work together so it makes sense yeah
we're gonna be out what's up what's our
sick sick uh
how much time do we have two weeks yeah
oh well i think we're gonna be sick for
a little while yeah and they're gonna be
like okay okay okay we get it because
what what are they really mad about you
tweeted what can brown do for you the
ups slogan they don't care about that no
it's just
they don't they are trying to avoid
reputational damage and they made a huge
miscalculation because they thought that
firing me was the easy thing to do this
would get the
bad actors off of their back they'd stop
getting emails sent to corporate and
they could go and tell the ceo or
whoever see we took care of this problem
what they didn't what they thought was
going to happen was that i was going to
sit down and shut the hell up and not
tell anybody because i'd be so
embarrassed well the opposite is true
i'm pissed off i think it's horrible and
i'm going to drag them to the ends of
the earth to destroy their reputation
as publicly and as loudly as i possibly
can and i'm going to get as many other
conservatives and independent thinkers
on my side to also try to destroy their
reputation because that's all i know how
to do at this point i wouldn't call it
destroying i would say be honest about
sure expose expose expose ruth yes yeah
and that's what i've been committed to
my entire career um so i i don't know
like what they thought that
i was or who i was
but that's not it corporate media is
such a
joke it's like like you need to your
court your media run through a filter of
an authoritarian corporation hell no
it's individual yeah now people can go
up there with the camera and get it done
man you don't need these stupid
companies yeah this is why i think we're
particularly lucky with tim cast in that
we have no external influences
no beneficiaries no investors
the only person that could ever be like
i'm the i'm the buck stops with me so
and and i'm kind of hot-headed and you
know
people call me arrogant and all that
stuff if somebody got fired i wouldn't
be like hey like we don't we don't want
to step on any toes here because you
know they're a big company we advertise
i'm going to be like uh let's let's take
the emails let's throw them down on the
table take pictures of them post them on
the internet put our feet up and crack a
cigar and tell everybody exactly what
happened yeah i i feel the exact same
way and that was my instinct as soon as
this happened i talked to a lot of
people about it i spent a month letting
people internally try to do what they
could do i explored some legal options i
was an at-will employee so there's not a
whole lot you can do in that situation
and their social media policy let me see
if i can bring it up because this is
kind of interesting i think it's pretty
obvious that this is a cya policy and it
exists so that they can fire people for
any reason whatsoever that's usually the
way they have it one thing i'll say too
as you're pulling it up
this is what the wright needs to
understand about uh activism when i
worked for non-profits they would do
postcarding where these nonprofit
organizations would hire people and have
them fill out postcards they would have
them go outside and ask people to just
sign their name to a postcard then they
would take thousands and put them all in
the mailbox and then one day a member of
congress just like here as you go here
you go and they wheelbarrow in all the
postcards and just leave them in their
room and they're like wow look at all
these people who are angry you know i
better act this way or i better react to
this you get 50 people who send emails
to a serial company and the ceo
company's like oh no everybody wants us
to do something so lucky charms better
go woke and in this instance the woke
started sending emails to to wmal right
and then they say oh just fire it'll
make it all go away yeah because they
know
or they're hoping that conservatives
won't email them complaining that they
fired someone over a twitter joke
because
the left is just chaotic and and and out
for some kind of
yeah i don't know the crazy thing is
4chan had this reputation for the
longest time
of you know don't mess with 4chan
they'll come after you
now i guess for whatever reason you
don't really hear a lot about that it's
it's the left who hasn't has has become
the hornet's nest remember remember it
was a colbert talking about anonymous
and he was talking about this company
called i think it was h what was it uh
what was it called hp gary was that what
it was i don't know no it's something
federal i don't know maybe it was hpg
but uh colbert was talking about the
security company that went after
anonymous and he said that's like saying
you know they wanted to stick their dick
in a hornet's nest and then kick it or
something like that
it used to be
4chan
and the libertarian and the right that
were the hornets nest to be feared not
to screw with
now it's antifa on the left because the
corporations are terrified of them and
the right doesn't do anything they call
it brigading is that what it's called we
get a bunch of people to go do something
i i kind of realized the power that 2007
i think obama was running for office i
was like oh we can get this guy elected
let's all vote for obama everyone
listening vote for obama i would just
tell people vote for obama yeah and they
did it and then i was like we could all
pull our ba our money out of the bank at
the same moment on the same day i was
like i think it might be is that illegal
to call for that no i don't think so so
like mad power and then i started to get
scared like oh if i did that and crash
the economy that could be very bad yeah
power of brigading is real and there are
a lot of
sort of more formal left-wing advocacy
organizations like sleeping giants that
were formed on social media and do these
harassment campaigns media matters is
sort of infamous for going after
people's advertisers they basically
managed to bully all of tucker carlson's
advertisers out of being on his show for
example um because they just for them
it's it's not obviously not about oh we
really care about racism and sexism and
homophobia and all that they care about
just trying to shut up anybody who
disagrees with them politically that's
the real goal
because they use these things so
dishonestly but i have the social media
policy here
so the only thing that i could think of
that this potentially violated
was
employees must not use internet venues
in a manner that may cause public
discredit to employee or to the company
so like i said it's a cya it's if we if
you do anything we don't like whether
on-air or off-air we can fight fire you
under this policy and you that will be
considered firing for cause we don't owe
you any severance you lose all of your
union benefits and you're screwed uh and
then they probably assume that people
will be scared by the confidential
confidentiality aspect of this handbook
and not talk about it uh but again that
wasn't gonna happen but your tweet was
so
just not even
i mean like what if you called kamala a
disgusting pig you know
that's a good question he would have
been fine i think yeah yeah i think i
probably would have been okay the word
brown yeah the people have become that
sensitive to this insanity yeah uh that
that you're talking about colors like if
what can you know if you use red they
wouldn't have done anything about it
it's the color brown black white the
shades black and white are very
sensitive words yellow is another one
you can't do that that's in okay you can
you just well that's why i use tone we
can take a box of lucky charms oh the
camera's not oh no yes we can we can put
a box of lucky charms next to sheamus or
sheamus chose to do it and someone sent
it to him and everyone laughed and it's
funny that he's like you know i'm irish
so there's leprechauns or whatever do
you guys think the corporations should
have the right to do that what they did
to you
oh yeah absolutely yes it's a cultural
problem
company companies should be able to uh
for the most part fire people for you
know any reason i say for the most part
there's probably certain circumstances
where you know
like
retaliation after you abuse someone
physically and things like that but i
don't know why you'd want to work there
so maybe we should just let companies
sever with you know people if they if
they want to there's probably a longer
conversation there but uh the issue is
the culture yeah a company shouldn't
want to do that
and and not only that if a company says
well you put up a mean tweet about the
you know the the brown vice president so
we're firing you and then if the other
five people were like we quit
that even even even that among the
employees would prevent the the
corporations oh yeah you could build you
could build organization within the the
company's employees to resist this kind
of behavior but
20th century corporations which is what
they are right now aren't equipped to
handle 21st century media because
they're getting bombarded through a
central service with all these 50 100
people sending emails to this one guy or
this small group of people and they're
overloading their uh their like helpline
i think what's interesting in my case is
the backlash wasn't that big i mean i've
had people try to cancel me before and
this was relatively minor in comparison
it was like maybe 10 people sent an
email i would guess it wasn't this
bombardment that would really lead any
honest like real
leader to say
this is too much like this girl's got to
go she's causing us a huge headache and
when you have this policy that talks
about how you can't discredit the
company like in my from my perspective
again this is a huge miscalculation
because they are now being publicly
discredited
5 10 50 times more
than they would have otherwise because
of this decision to fire me you know
exactly that's good i i have to say this
i honestly don't care about kamala
harris's outfit being all brown it is
weird so i actually have some some i
have i have a i have other clothes this
may be shocking to many people but i
have a brown button up and then i have
you know like round t-shirts and one day
i was like let's see like what should i
wear when i go skate or go out and then
i looked at them both and i'm like man i
would totally look like i worked for ups
if i wore that definitely
so you're a racist too yeah the problem
with pamela is her her jacket's the same
color as the desk that's a big mistake
so it'd be like if you had it your shirt
was the same color as the wall behind
you it would look crazy it's not a great
shade of brown in my opinion but yeah
it's like poop brown yeah yeah like what
was she thinking it does look like the
poop emoji yeah what can brown do for
you well for kamala harris her outfit
not a lot that is like the ups color too
yeah it is i mean people have put the
ups logo on her lips jacket yeah it was
a meme and it was dead on
dead on
well people just got a
you know you know there needs to be
conservative activist organizations and
i hate saying the word conservative
because that's not even the issue just
not woke yeah there needs to be not not
stupid yeah civil libertarian i think is
the is the right word that encompasses
conservatives and moderates civil
libertarian like
there's a there's a tweet going around
from some dude and he's like canceled
culture has no place in america then
it's like the night i think defiant
elves posted this and the next the next
tweet is him saying disney should be
straight
and i'm like that's not cancel culture
not at all right people think that not
spending your money with a certain
business is cancer culture now like
that's the left's new talking point is
that if you do anything like they
boycott people all the time right
but and then when conservatives do it
they're like no no you're doing the
cancel culture now you're doing the
cancel those are saying boycotts and
sanctions are not the same thing cancel
culture are when you're fired from a job
for saying something or banned from
twitter that's a sanction
cancel culture is digging up messages
and taking them out of context
taking messages out of context it's when
you get someone fired or harassed for
something that is not genuine for the
most part saying disney does awful
things so we shouldn't provide them with
any services and give them the boot is
just being like this is a bad company
who literally does things they don't
like that's the whole point of having a
free market capitalist system is that
you're supposed to be able to spend your
dollars where you want to and and be
able to make those sort of more moral
decisions about your finances and then
i'd also add that i think cancel culture
is when the punishment doesn't fit the
crime so if you're trying to get someone
fired for a tweet that is an unjust
consequence for something that they
supposedly did wrong what's my question
to you then do you think the corporation
should be able to fire people like that
like whenever they want
i mean if i signed an at-will contract
so they're within their right to do so i
spend a lot of time on social media and
thinking like should social media
companies have the ability to ban
whoever they want at any time and i
usually land on yeah because i think
ultimately what we're going to head
towards is
near infinite amounts of social media
networks all working in parallel with
different terms of service all the
different networks will have different
terms and all the code will be similar
so they'll all be interoperating
um i just don't see that corporations at
the moment i don't know how to stop
these authoritarians from just
destroying someone's livelihood at will
did you guys see that story about uh
i think lori lightfoot is going to give
away was it 50 000 gas cards yeah yeah
and i was thinking about that's kind of
funny like what do you call it when it's
communism but it's not for everyone it's
only for a randomly selected lottery and
i was like is that
demar communism something like that like
like only ten percent get to bask in the
comments randomism welcome to our new
government well well democratic one
demarchy is random government people are
randomly chosen to realize like demar
communism yeah but anyway i bring this
up because i'm thinking like you know
what we should do for for tim cast is
just whenever there's like layoffs we'll
just
have uh everyone will have to hold the
potato
and then
whoever's holding the potato when the
buzzer goes off is fired and so everyone
will constantly be throwing it but like
if you throw it no one catches it it's
it's yours and we got cameras we'll know
so you gotta get someone else to catch
it yeah and then everyone will be
throwing it to each other and then you
never know and then we'll just like
never put the buzz around for like a
week so everyone's just walking around
throwing a potato around that's that's
nice that's sliding his pockets when he
doesn't know the appropriate way
the whole time thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there